[Music]
and welcome to the supercharged
performance session we're going to talk
about GPUs today how many of you have
used GPUs on in a data center before
raise your hand
Oh quite a few that's good how many in
the cloud used to be the cloud before ok
so some of you have had the fun
experience of setting up your own GPUs
and some of had the experience of
spinning them up in just using them
remotely so we're going to talk about
why people are interested in GPUs and
we're going to tell you about how GPUs
are available in Google compute engine
and remind you why you should be so
happy about and anyone that set up GPS
before should know that already
and then I'll walk you through how you
provision a GPU instance but the
highlight of our talk today will be
three demonstrations one from map D who
will be showing amazing data and Linux
very fast data analytics using GPUs in
the cloud and then Schlumberger is going
to talk about how they do seismic
high-performance computing with GPUs and
Google Cloud and then we'll talk about
remote workstations so when we get
started so this is must be familiar to
most of you if you've done much
scientific or engineering work or work
in machine learning you know a lot of
that requires matrix operations and
these matrices can be very large you
know sometimes you know a thousand by a
thousand or larger and the nice thing
about GPUs is they can do some of these
operations in parallel so for instance
multiplying a X in order to get B each
individual element of a can be
multiplied by an element of X in
parallel independently of all the other
ones but of course then you have to
gather up some of that information not
quite as parallel when it comes time to
add those together but still very
parallel parallel and the nice thing
about GPUs they have a lot of course for
doing these operations in parallel so
just a quick overview CPUs typically
have on the order of dozens of threads
that can do these operations
simultaneously but GPUs have in some
cases two orders of magnitude a hundred
times as many and so they can do you
know these calculations simultaneously
and the other thing that's nice about
GPUs is they have lots of memory
bandwidth
sometimes an order of magnitude
additional memory bandwidth so if you
have a lot of data to turn through you
can push data through very quickly
through those cores so I have a little
animation to show you how that works
a CPU is very flexible can do lots of
different types of operations on the
data that flows through and it can scale
up to dozens of cores simultaneously so
you can crank a lot of data through a
CPU a GPU has higher memory bandwidth so
it can push some data through streaming
data through more quickly and then can
scale up to thousands of course
simultaneously so you can imagine if you
have a lots of operations to do you can
do a lot more work all at once so one
example of that is Amber molecular
dynamics software where you can do a
simulation of the interaction of
molecules together and this chart shows
you that in some cases using CPU nodes
up to 100 CPU notes
I'm sorry 48 - processor CPU nodes you
can get up to around 20 nanoseconds of
simulation per day so 20 nanoseconds
everyday takes a lot of days to get up
to a single day of simulation with the
GPU get two and a half times that
performance with three nodes of four
GPUs and NVIDIA was kind enough to share
some data with us our partner
they have mentioned that GPU developer
interest is increasing substantially we
have over three times as many developers
signed up now in the past two years up
to 400,000 and more than 20,000
organizations engage with Nvidia for
deep learning activities and you can see
that the major deep learning frameworks
are all GPU enabled now accelerated by
GPUs so what are the things you can do
with the GPU raise your hand if you've
done some of these things machine
learning who's done machine learning so
good number group frame rendering image
composition a few people here physical
simulation analysis Fe M few people
real-time visual analytics on an SQL
database you'll see that one today we're
gonna show demo
how about faster than real-time 4k video
encoding or transcoding yeah we've got
someone here that's excited about that
sequence mapping and
or subsurface analysis for the oil and
gas industry I should see some ants from
summers day over here they'll be talking
about that later so just to give you
some examples were going to be talking
about v-ray today where we have more
than 100 k DG P use that would be on the
order of 500 teraflops of performance
rendering massive models in real time
and then we're going to show a demo of
map DS real-time visual analytics where
they use a parallel processing power and
high memory bandwidth of the GPU GPU to
query billions of rows at a time and I
like to highlight this quote which is
also on our web page that single hi
ma'am
32 instance with 8 GPUs was almost a
hundred times faster 85 times faster
than Impala running on a cluster of six
CPU nodes so that's an example of real
value so as you know we have Katie's
available today in beta we've announced
and will soon deliver s 93 hundreds from
AMD and NVIDIA Tesla p1 hundreds a lot
of enthusiasm for the P 100's coming up
and right now they're available in the
US Europe and Asia and this as I
mentioned before offers tell us our
flops of performance per instance and
for especially for machine learning
engineering simulations and molecular
modeling you can attach as I mentioned
also H VP use eight GPUs per virtual
machine and you can do either one two
four or eight simultaneously we have
them in three regions today and then we
have another region us West coming in
line within the next few weeks one thing
that people really like about the GPUs
in Google cloud is that we offer
essentially bare-metal performance we're
offering them through a pass-through
mode which means they're directly
attached to the cpu that your VM is
running on so it's directly attached you
get high performance and you can attach
GPUs to any machine type so you have a
lot of flexibility as well
and since we charge only per minute with
a 10-minute minimum you can choose GPU
that best fits your wallet and also pay
only for what you use
you don't have to worry so much about if
you're using it for a full hour or a
fraction of an hour and then you don't
have to make a capital investment -
which is a huge advantage
I think pricing is available online but
I thought I'd mention it here that it's
a 70 cents per GPU per hour for the K
eighties in the US and the apparent Asia
or each 77 cents per hour per GPU now
then here's the nice thing is again
people raise their hand earlier if
you've installed the GPU before you know
it's a lot of work to do that buying the
hardware waiting for it to arrive buying
the system that surrounds that the
networking putting it all together
assembling it it doesn't work the first
time why is that you know as a GPU bad
did I see the card correctly in the
board it's really a lot of it's a
challenge and you have to have the
physical space and the other thing is
you know hardware does fail who manages
the fleet and make sure the harder fails
it gets replaced and fixed but I think
one of the biggest things is power and
cooling so if you're thinking about
running 100 GPUs somewhere those GPUs
put out a lot of heat into your data
center right or into the closet you're
putting them in and so you have to be
careful or you might install more GPUs
than your cooling system can handle and
actually not be able to run them at the
high performance we've taken care of
that for you so if you use GPUs in the
cloud you have to worry about any of
these things just step you through what
it takes to provision a GPU and the
cloud I was going to suggest that
someone get out their computer and start
putting together a GPU machine right now
you can start ordering online to order a
GPU and see how long it takes you in the
meantime we'll have a race
we'll see how quickly we can get one up
in the cloud I think I'm going to win so
you go to the GPU to the console and you
choose the compute engine tab and click
on the create instance button and then
you can choose customize that's where
the GPS are hidden right now once you
choose customize you'll see that you can
choose the number of cores and how much
memory you want and there's a little GPU
link you can click on underneath and you
can choose the number of GPUs you want
and the type of course the type right
now is the K 80 and the number you can
choose one two four or eight as I
mentioned before now if you prefer to
use the command line here's an example
of command line for provisioning a GPU
instance
and the main thing to pay attention to
is the accelerator option with type and
count to say what you want
so either either one will get you a GPU
now I want to mention two GPUs don't
support live migration because we're
offering them in pass-through mode to
get the high performance we don't
actually have the capacity to capture
the information in the GPU the current
state of the GPU in the memory and move
that over to another physical GPU so
when it's time for maintenance we notify
you give you one hour notification and
the GPU terminates one hour after we
give you a notification and you can
we'll give you some support for that if
you watch the VM metadata you can see
that if you run this command you'll get
a none if maintenance is not scheduled
or you'll get a timestamp that says when
the maintenance is going to happen and
so based on the timestamp you neither
reboot right away and get a new machine
or you can checkpoint what you're
working on save it and bring it back up
in a new instance and I mentioned I
should have mentioned that the
information about how to do that is
online in this link and then if you're
using tensorflow we make it even easier
you can use Tantra foes supervisor and
that allows you to manage banks of GPU
based VMs and it handles both shutdowns
and crashes cleanly easily resumed so
you don't lose any data because
especially when you're doing machine
learning training I'm like it might run
for weeks at a time and you don't want
to lose your work do a due to a
maintenance event so now I'd like to
invite Todd up on the the stage to give
a demonstration introduce himself and
give a demonstration thanks John
everyone really excited to be here today
tell you a little bit about nap T which
is a GPU accelerated database and visual
analytics platform and would really like
to thanks John and the Google cloud team
we're tremendously excited about what
Google is bringing to market here in
terms of their GPU instances there's a
lot of flexibility for developers
there's a lot of flexibility for
startups like us to basically niche and
match mix and match components and
deliver the perfect system so just a
little bit about us we are series a
startup
have some great investors including
Google as well as Nvidia we've won some
awards we regard our cool vendor last
year and have had a good set of early
customers including Verizon Wireless who
I'll be speaking with at strata next
week so everybody knows that
organizations are awash in data so
they're saying that data growth is
actually 40 percent year-over-year for
your average organization and storage is
not the issue right so people can put
the data on disk they're building
massive data lakes massive Hadoop
clusters storage is not the issue the
issue is when you actually want to
analyze this data so if data is growing
at a forty percent year-over-year rate
compute our CPU computers actually only
growing at a twenty percent
year-over-year rate and so this compute
gap between the growth and data and the
growth in CPU is causing people to do
all sorts of unnatural things people
downsample people pre aggregate people
basically have to deploy huge scale out
clusters of hundreds if not thousands of
nodes with diminishing returns to scale
and so people are at this impasse and
that's where GPUs come in so I don't
want to reiterate what John has said but
GPUs are not only fast but they're their
processing power is growing at a
tremendous rate and not only is it
keeping up with the growth and data but
it's actually surpassing it so whether
you measure by compute bandwidth or by
memory bandwidth you have a huge amount
of throughput on GPUs and I'd like to
point out that everybody pays attention
to flops and certainly GPUs deliver
they're actually if you look at the
memory bandwidth that's almost more
important for data analytics problems
where things are often memory bandwidth
bound so that's where math D comes in so
map D was built from the ground up to
leverage the massive parallelism and
memory bandwidth of these graphics
processing units to literally deliver
you know hundred plus X speed ups over
CPU systems on an equal Hardware cost
basis going back to that quote that John
showed earlier comparing us to Impala
and so you can run these crazy fast
sequel queries over billions of rows
sub-second allowing for the first time
truly interactive exploration of big
datasets and because one of the killer
use cases is so
often slice-and-dice visual analytics we
built not the immerse which is the
web-based visual analytics engine which
not only leverages the speed of these
GPUs but the ability of the GPUs to
render graphics so we sort of use it as
a one-two punch where we can run the
sequel query over billions of rows and
because you often don't want to actually
transmit all that data back to the
client we can actually render it
Institute right on the GPUs using the
graphics price processing pipeline and
render in place and send back a
compressed PNG so with that I'm gonna
cut to a quick demo here okay everybody
see my screen great so this is a
relatively sizable data set this is 2
billion records basically all the ship
is or ship transponder data from
throughout 2015
what's notable here is that we're
running on a single 8k 80 or a GPU 4k 80
Google compute instance so if you tried
to imagine the amount of compute you
need to bring a bear that allow
interactive querying on this data set on
a CPU cluster it's pretty amazing where
we're doing this on a single node so
you'll see all kinds of different
metrics here number of unique ships
histogram of vessel linked destinations
here's actually the ship ID so we can
drill down to an individual ship speed
vessel type time and then last off you
have this map which is actually all the
points color coded by the vessel type so
this is an example of map these back-end
rendering capability what we call our
iris rendering engine you wouldn't want
to actually send 2 billion records from
your server to your client so we
actually render and rasterize that on
our back-end on top of the sequel query
almost as a visual UDF and then spit out
a PNG and interactive PNG to the client
so the cool thing here is that actually
as i zoom in here you're gonna notice
that basically i'm gonna go into the bay
area everything updates in real time and
actually each one of these charts is
hitting the backend with a query that's
probably responding in about 30 or 40
milliseconds and that's why we can be so
interactive even at the scale even on a
single node because we're leveraging the
power of these GPUs to basically brute
force these queries
and answer them and you know a fraction
at a time you could on a CPU based
system so as i zoom in here I can look
you know what if I actually wanted to
see the fastest vessels so I'm going to
kind of cross filter here and look at
number of records here where people are
going about 20 knots and then I can see
all these records I'll notice first off
that if I increase this even farther
most of the fastest boats are actually
passenger boats so I could drill down
into that and see we'll see these
passenger boats and then I could
actually find an individual boat here
and drill down and actually we could
even zoom in and see their exact tracks
across the bay area here so it's a
pretty fun it's a pretty fun dataset and
you can again get very granular so if we
actually go off and look basically out
into the bay you can actually see where
the tankers sit and they circle here and
they moor which is pretty cool I'm going
to quickly show you one other thing how
am i doing on time let's see okay just
two more minutes so we not only built
map D or our immersed visual analytics
platform to be fast but we also built it
to be very easy to use so if what if I
want to explore the relationship between
speed let's see here I'm gonna go to a
scatter plot what if we wanted to look
at this place the relationship between
vessel length and we'll put that on the
x-axis and speed which is sog here so we
immediately have this scatter plot and
again this is actually leveraging the
power of the GPUs to do this on the back
end and here for good measure I'm
actually going to color by the type of
boat so immediately here you can see
that the kind of the bigger the boat
gets the longer the boat gets the faster
it goes except the the smaller boats the
slow ones are the tugboats here but the
longer ones are passenger and other
types of ships so I could easily build
on this if I wanted to I could add
another chart and
and cross filter but it's very
interactive and easy to use and this
kind of interactive data exploration at
scale is something that map D really
excels at so thank you hello
hi everyone I'm canipe attic I'm from
Sambhaji how many of you attended the
keynote speaker this speech this morning
alright quite a few so you heard our CTO
mr. Ashok Milani talked about the high
performance computing work in oil field
and our history of using CPUs and GPUs
and so we're going to talk about how we
are using now GPUs in cloud and thank
you John and thank you google it has
been an exciting journey so far and
we're just getting warmed up so all
right so slumber Jay very briefly what
do we do we provide insight into
subsurface everything below the earth
and the layers and structures and where
the carbo hydrocarbons are this is a set
of services that we provide our customer
we are technology company and so high
performance computing especially is
quite relevant to our one service that
I'm going to talk about today is the oil
exploration and we call it you know
seismic processing seismic acquisition
all right what's interesting for us as
computer scientists is the volume of
data that we acquire volume of data that
we need to process and for that we have
massive high-performance computing
centers around the world just dedicated
for seismic processing these centers
have been they how everything from
building to power cooling space to CPUs
GPUs storage and we've been doing that
for quite a number of years quite
successfully so you can look at the
volumes of the amount of data that we
acquire an amount of data that we have
to process
it requires so it requires a lot of
computing power and let me talk about
the seismic exploration you know very
brief two steps steps um step number one
we acquire data and as you can see we
acquire a large amount of data per job
or per project and we cover kilometres
and kilometres square mile square
kilometers of area around the globe the
step number two is to process em to
build the subsurface understanding
what's really going on down there
that requires massive amount of
computing millions of course millions of
GPU millions of threads and GPUs and it
is the classic high-performance
computing that we've been doing for many
years so the question we started asking
ourself couple years ago and prior to
that perhaps a little bit can we do this
massive parallel computing in cloud
effectively for business can we do it
for all the workflows that we need to do
it seismic not just one or two
algorithms and the answer is today yes
we are doing commercial work in Google
Cloud using compute engine with GPU
without that it would not have been
possible how do we do this I'm going to
invite my colleague Carlos to talk about
that thank you thank you can I
all right so how do we do seismic
processing we have strong requirements
on dynamic resource allocation data
management and fault tolerance this is
because of the nature of our business
the way we do processing right and
because of these requirements we try to
avoid using MPI or most of the classic
HPC high performance computing
frameworks so a few years back we built
our own software stack for our own data
centers and that stack provides a
MapReduce like kind of infrastructure
that introduced sufficient amounts of
fault tolerance and dynamic resource
management and it contains so for doing
this it contains basically has its own
custom job scheduler and custom resource
and data management layers as we brought
that softer stack that we built for our
own data centers into the cloud some
things were familiar like for instance
the nvidia ka DS right which provided
great performance per dollar and other
things were essentially opportunities so
some of those opportunities were the
ability to dynamically create instances
dynamically adapt the VMS
characteristics to match the performance
requirements of the jobs and some of
those were like for instance the the
needs for monitoring and control were a
opportunity these guys that's a
challenge right so in the graph here you
will notice I know you can't quite read
the details but you'll notice there are
three main layers on this right under
the top layer you have a very small
number of nodes which contain what I
call the durable infrastructure right
these are the pieces that make the
virtual data center work it's a small
number of nodes like the job controller
now the middle layer is the bulk of the
data center as a bulk of it are the
compute nodes these are what we call the
ephemeral infrastructure and they're
basically live for the length of a job
you create those nodes on demand size
and dimension for what your job needs
and the bottom of the layer is basically
composed of a parallel file system that
feeds the data through those to the
compute nodes and has a lifecycle that
is independent of the other two layers
now finally what we have is a we call it
of fat linkage a 20 GB link between our
data center in Houston and Google data
centers and that allows us to basically
upload or move the data the massive
amounts of data that we have between
Houston and between our data center and
Google right and when I say a massive
amount of data basically a job commonly
requires 60 to 100 terabytes of input
data to start running so to give you an
example in this case here we have a
single imaging job so this is running
reverse time migration and last for a
few days we run it last weekend this was
probably about three days and as you can
see in the curve here on the on your
right on your left
it starts with twenty nodes and it
acquires nodes are his scales up so at
its peak it has a little bit more than
1700 nodes and then it ramps down as the
finish if the works to the work to be
done right so I I really get excited
about this kind of problem because of
the massive scale of these computations
so at the peak we are using about 7,000
GPUs and we are using something around
20,000 CPUs for that single job now this
is not the only job that we're running
right and oh and by the way we were
generating about 220 gigabytes per
second of i/o combined but again this is
not the single job we were running and
it's not unusual that we run multiple
jobs at any given time as a matter of
fact if you look at the other graph the
green one you see a
the utilization curve for what we are
calling our virtual data center right so
it's a it's the footprint at Google and
as you see you have periods that have
about 50 nodes and we go from fifty to
five thousand nodes within two three
hours which well I find it's pretty cool
so to conclude I would like to reveal
some of the opportunities we found which
was the ability to basically use the
GPUs that are familiar to us that
provide great performance and the
ability to resize and dynamically create
and delete VMs on demand so we create
the matter of fact I think we create
usually a few thousands VMs per day
create and delete and that comes with a
price of you have to be obsessed about
organizing monitoring and control your
Center but by leveraging these
opportunities we have successfully
deployed a virtual data center what we
call virtual data center Google which
uses thousands of CPUs and GPUs every
day and do massive seismic processing
for production work set of production
workloads today
thank you myself Hey how you doing
everybody everybody can hear me in the
back mics okay sorry my name is Adrian
Graham I'm a cloud solutions architect
at Google in the Venice office that's
Venice California not Venice Italy
although the food in the office is still
pretty good and I come from a background
a visual effects background so I spent
20 years as a pipeline TD and as an
effects artist at companies like ILM
Digital Domain double- in London I
worked on some big films and rendering
is one of the big components of working
on any film and that's what we're gonna
look at today we're going to look at
what a renderer can do in the cloud and
what it can do furthermore
on the GPU so what is a renderer need
what is the role in the pipeline of
somebody was a renderer or who performs
rendering actions is a lighter and they
take all of the assets all of the
massive amounts of data that's generated
by modelers and texture artists and
animators and those are simple assets
this the complex assets are things like
simulation data and complex character
rigs and massive environments like if
you have to lay out an entire city the
island of Manhattan could be all
completely virtually generated and what
do you do with all that data and how do
you move it around and shift it so the
render the the the lighting artist will
take all this data and they'll make a
beautiful image out of it and they'll
use a renderer today we're going to look
at a renderer called v-ray by chaos
group but to step back what is a what is
a lighter need to do their job they need
a very powerful workstation not a laptop
you need multi-core good GPUs lots of
memory lots of RAM and lots of disk
storage all these assets that are
generated prior to the light are getting
their hands on them take up massive
amounts of space and that's as the data
is coming in the data is going out a
lighter is generating frames we don't
render movie files we render individual
frames 24 frames in a second that's 24
images and they could be HD res there
could be 4k that can be 8k they could be
stereo pairs massive amounts are
required
you need licensing you need to be able
to license the software on the
workstation as well as the render boxes
you need color accuracy so that
everybody's seeing the same picture and
of course you need as many render
workers as possible and that's the the
classic description of a lighting
pipeline today we're going to look at a
project by our friend Kevin Margo kevin
is a let me just say these guys kevin is
a VFX supervisor at blur Studios in Los
Angeles and Kevin did this short film
called construct or construct however
you want to say it it's about this robot
construction worker who shows up on the
site one day to find something horrible
what's going on you can see it on
YouTube it's a really great short film
but on the right-hand side of your
screen you're seeing the making of
had some pretty is this visionary
director he's got some pretty
interesting ideas about how to do
virtual sets and virtual motion-capture
sessions and you could see the guy in
the suit does Darren Ross he is wearing
a motion capture suit with with points
on it that are being tracked by a bunch
of cameras that data is being fed into
3d studio max which is the 3d
application and being rendered in real
time by v-ray v-ray RT in this case in
the video you'll also see Boris right
the seaman Dolph who's in the audience
today with us
boris is the director of v-ray cloud and
IT at Kaos did I get that right thanks
there's also some pretty revolutionary
cinematography techniques that Kevin has
figured out and that they're using a
virtual camera there's no real-world
camera it's a CG it's a camera that is
simply that rig that you saw with the
screen tracked by the director so that
you could really visualize what's going
on and what it's going to the final
result is going to look like that also
means that you're not storing massive
amounts of data you're only storing the
positional data for the for the camera
itself now this is the onset preview
that on the right hand side that you're
watching but on the left hand side
that's the final render the final render
in this case they tried a bunch of
different ways to render it they used
CPUs each frame took about two to four
hours to render and they tried GPUs and
this is a couple years ago so there was
the setups were a lot different and they
didn't have the power that we have on
GCP and those renders took about those
18 minutes or so so what if we could do
this on a Google cloud platform and let
me stop these guys well it just so
happens that we can so before I start
I'm running a remote workstation I'm not
running Windows on my Mac I'm running a
remote workstation in u.s. central which
is in Iowa which is about 1500 miles
away 40 second 40 millisecond round-trip
ping and this is the full scene that you
there and I am going to track around a
bit and show that oh I'm sorry my mouse
wheel is a little bit wonky there but
I'm going to zoom out this is operating
over Internet so it's a little bit slow
but the render is happening almost in
real time and you got to remember how
much data is being generated in this
scene each of these it's doing geometry
substitution on-the-fly each of those
red pyramids it's being substituted for
a full resolution tree and you could
zoom into the forest you could select a
single object and zoom in on it
there's the dumpster I can go back to
let me just go back to the robots and
the whole idea behind this is not just
to move around your scene but you can
change lighting and you could change
animation and you can change shading
qualities step back one more I just want
to make this a little smaller so I can
see my robots and there we are my robots
seem to have disappeared but you guys
get the idea oh there we are let me just
show the entire these live demos all
right so I have hosed my hose my demo
but that give you an idea of what's
going on in the cloud come see me after
I could get it running again so how do
we do this this is a sort of a little
bit more complex architectural diagram
of how we did this what we're doing
right now for example we're not doing
any asset management database or we're
not sinking our cloud directory user
database but we are using something
called we're running over terror DGP CEO
IP which is PC over IP which is a remote
desktop protocol developed by a company
called tera dieci and you can run this
on a piece of hardware there's this zero
client which just has a bunch of video
outs and an
Internet port and some USBs and there's
also a software client which is running
what I'm running on my on my Mac here
there's one for Windows and there is one
for iOS devices as well which is pretty
cool
boris has it running on his on his phone
it's not even iOS it's Android right
it's running in a browser we are also
running a remote machine running 3d
studio max and a bunch of render
instances the render instances are
running Linux and OS seven and as you
saw unfortunately
the interactive remote desktop machine
is running Windows an ancient version I
apologize for that there's some plugins
that I don't want to talk about and then
there's a license server I'm running a
Linux license server that's feeding
licenses to both the render instances
and the remote desktop and of course
we're rendering using v-ray and those
are licensed via the cloud as well so
how do we set all this up
quite simply first we want to create a
workstation and there's three important
points I want to indicate on these on
this slide here is that number one we
choose our zone and as you as John said
earlier it's going to be available in
number of different zones West is us
West is coming up very soon had it
already been running we would be we
would be running there the the ping time
it'll be much faster you choose your GPU
type obviously we have our K 80s right
now and you choose your image GPUs can
attach to an instance running any one of
our public images any of different
flavors of Linux and different flavors
of Windows so that's our remote display
workstation and finally we want to run
an agent which will allow us to run the
terror deechi protocol then we want to
create a render worker but we want to
create the perfect instance that we will
then replicate in a managed instance
group so the two important points here
are one they're in the same zone for
maximum throughput and - we don't delete
the boot disk when the machine goes away
and I'll show you why that is so you set
this machine up perfectly with all the
software or the hooks and the licensing
that you need and then you take it down
and you save the disk and you turn it
into an image which gets turned into a
template the template gets deployed
across your manage and instance groups
and the final important point here is
that you're running your you're running
a startup script when each of this
machines boot so we want to run the the
v-ray standalone server mode which you
could see here runs on a particular open
port and that means that we can take
from a list of these servers these are
all the machines that the that studio 3d
studio max is rendering on and we and so
once the machine boots up you can you
can use a command to to view the the
serial port output to watch it to watch
the progress in to troubleshoot and
finally we you launch a managed an
entire managed instance group which is
completely dynamic you could size it up
or down if you want to minimize your
costs you start with only two CPUs or
sorry two VMs and then once it's ready
you deploy another 30 of them and as
long as the IPS are all fed into your
render options the renderer will start
to expand and run on all these machines
it's unbelievably powerful so when you
think that these things these frames
took two to four hours on CPUs and 18
minutes on on older GPUs that were in a
different type of Nvidia cluster we're
getting almost real-time performance
here finally there's some some helpful
commands that I use all the time - for
example and this the top section here
I'm tailing the the serial port output
and on the bottom I can view all of my
all of my running instances to get an
idea of whether IP czar and everything
and to see their status whether they're
they're being terminated or whether
they're coming up are still booting and
that is pretty important when I want to
resize my instance groups or or stop the
entire group entirely I think we're
going to finish off by what John was
saying earlier is that the p100 switcher
display capable are coming soon very
very exciting and AMD cards as well I
don't know the specifics behind that but
just to summarize what we saw here today
we're run
v-ray RT by chaos we're running 3d
studio max 128 K 80 GPUs there's 32
instances each with 4 GPUs and we're
running over terror DT PC over IP in a
software client variant all running on
the single Google central one region 40
millisecond ram trip latency and it's
1,500 miles away so all this is
happening in the cloud right now thank
you thanks Adrian so let's see what what
do we want you to remember from the
takeaway first of all thank you for the
everyone that came up and gave a demo
map t slumber J and Adrian from Google
showing how v-ray works with 128 K T's
running at the same time so fantastic
and and fun demos and I guess what I
want you to remember is you want
performance that's scalable and you know
come to Google Cloud and fire up a bunch
of GPUs and thanks for coming
[Music]
you